she you know
grabbed a switch and i got a really bad
whipping for it
and um
when i put on my uh
clothes to go to church one of the
welts from my back opened up and um
bloodied the
bloody the dress oprah who was raised by
her grandparents also
tearfully reveals to dr oz she's still
haunted
by the memories of domestic violence my
grandfather has his um
hands around my grandmother's neck and
she is screaming
and she manages to push him off of her
first time we talked about this cousin
henry comes down the road
in the middle of the night to help my
grandmother get my grandfather up off
the floor
and after that my grandmother put a
chair underneath
the doorknob and some tin cans
around the chair and that is how we
slept every night i'm sleeping i always
slept listening for the cans listening
for what happens if that doorknob moves
oprah's been open with it about
channeling her trauma into helping
others
we were there as she opened her school
for underprivileged girls
these are my girls these are our girls i
still think it is
a great service but out of 20 girls
five of them dr oz ended up in hospital
with depression and suicidal ideation
and i was distraught
oprah's now co-written a book revealing
how critical all adults are
in shaping a child's future and says she
is living proof
why aren't i stone crazy why don't i
have more problems
your relationships with people who cared
about you
eat other than your family members
changes the way
you view yourself and view the world
[Applause]
now oprah also added that while we think
children are so resilient she learned
that
the first two months of life are the
most important time that's interesting
oprah winfrey always being raw always
being open
and teaching yes always teaching